the episode that you are about to see
it's going to be important it's going to
be real it's going to be something that
will probably be deleted so i highly
urge you guys to watch this and share
this with every single person in your
family everyone that you care about your
loved ones and make sure you stick to
the end because it's very important
stuff the world as we know is about to
change very quickly i urge all of you to
protect yourselves
assalamu alaikum
without further ado let's go right in
[Music]
okay so one of the first things that
we're gonna notice when we're breaking
this down is there is a very peculiar
art style that is used throughout the
duration of this ad and it's something
that's known as the uncanny valley and
the uncanny valley is a style of art
that artists typically and almost always
try to stay away from because it makes
the viewer feel uncomfortable it's close
to reality but it's not quite reality
and this is by no means a mistake this
wasn't done on accident they didn't
accidentally make the art this way this
was 100 planned it is supposed to make
you feel
a little bit off
[Music]
this is the dimension of imagination so
the very first thing that i noticed when
i was watching this ad was just how
peculiar of a choice it was to put a
tiger eating a buffalo at the very
beginning of the ad for something that's
supposed to be so fun and this is a
virtual reality world that we can all
retreat to and have fun in and at the
end of the ad it says this is going to
be fun it kind of seems like a strange
choice and i don't really know why they
chose this that was my initial thought
but after a few days of sitting with it
i knew that there had to be more than
that so i spent a couple days doing some
pretty thorough research i found a few
examples of what's known as zoroastrian
petroglyphs and they depict a tiger
attacking and eating a buffalo and i
thought well what does that mean why
would they choose this are they even
related zoroastrianism is one of the
oldest and most widely practiced
religions in all of human history it's
just as old as christianity judaism and
even islam it's a cosmological
monotheistic religion meaning that they
only believe in one god and with that
they also believe in an anti-god or a
devil the devil in zoroastrianism being
known as ariman the god of darkness the
god of human confusion and if you've
seen my original video on the topic you
know what zoroastrian petroglyphs were
used to depict the god arymon so there's
undoubtedly some symbolic connection
there and before we move on one of the
more subtle things that i noticed was
the buffalo's eye to some of you you may
already know or you may have already
caught what i'm talking about but this
singular eye looks eerily similar to the
eye of raw or the eye of horus used in
egyptian mythology now more mainstream
conspiracy theorists would call this the
all-seeing eye or the trademark symbol
of the illuminati i'm not necessarily
saying that's what it is but
certainly very peculiar and i certainly
think it's important that we at least
ask these questions and have a discourse
about it the all-seeing eye is symbolic
of spiritual awakening and spiritual
consciousness and in this case in
particular it is very likely being used
as the eye of ra or in other words the
god of light now if you're somebody who
follows an abrahamic religion like
christianity judaism islam or even
zoroastrianism possibly you are likely
very familiar with the god of light
being lucifer otherwise known as satan
lucifer by definition meaning light
bearer so i'm gonna leave that there and
we'll touch on the eye again at the end
of this video
this is the dimension of imagination
okay so the next thing that i noticed
that was really strange is when the kids
walk up to the painting and they
acknowledge the tiger and they see that
the tiger is obviously attacking the
buffalo the tiger then stops and begins
to stroke the buffalo and smile and
almost befriend it in some kind of a
really odd way well there's a couple of
ways that i could connect this to the
real world first being that it is a
singular tiger attacking a singular
buffalo well in the wild tigers have to
divide and conquer their prey because
they can't attack a herd of buffalo all
at once so they've got to
make the numbers smaller and take them
out one by one this could be very easily
correlated to the powers that be in our
own world they can't conquer us all if
we all work together so they have to
purposely divide us from within and then
they conquer us so when the kids
acknowledge the tiger and what he's
doing the tiger immediately stops and
pretends to be their friend pretends to
be friendly pretends like he's not about
to murder this buffalo very similar to
what we see every four years secondly
and i'm not sure that this is really
connected but it this is weird tigers
actually do something similar to this in
the wild it's actually been recorded
that tigers will mimic the sounds of cow
and buffalo to lure them out of their
herd to be killed
they think you're one of us
crazy stuff this is the dimension of
imagination
[Music]
uh
[Music]
all right
this is the really weird part i'm gonna
get into something deep right now
so in occultic symbolism we see the use
of saturn and black cubes quite often
and i'm gonna explain why that is and
hopefully i do a good job of explaining
why the number six is so significant in
occultism as well so way back in the
land of mesopotamia before the land of
egypt had even been settled in so they
say there were a group of people who
lived in the middle eastern area known
as mesopotamia who knew a lot more and
were capable of a lot more than we give
them credit for they knew things about
our solar system that we have no idea
how people of the time knew and they
were able to build structures that stood
the test of time structures that we
can't even build ourselves today but one
of the most fascinating things to me
about these mesopotamians is their god
saturn the mesopotamians and the
sumerians who by the way predate the
egyptian empire knew that the number six
was correlated with saturn and if you
don't know by the way if you follow
religion from mesopotamia all the way
down to rome about 2 000 years ago
you'll find that saturn ariman
satan lucifer the devil all of these
characters draw parallels towards one
another they're not different characters
it is all the same being the antithesis
of all good and all creation in all
cases this devil character is being used
as the prince of darkness as humanity
grew from this time in mesopotamia and
people spread all across the world
religion began to change and a lot of
these characters changed their names but
a lot of them are the exact same
character in the same way that the epic
of gilgamesh and the story of noah's ark
is largely the exact same story told by
two different religions so what's really
interesting about this is that the
mesopotamians and the sumerians use a
six-sided star to represent their god
saturn this six-sided star would make
its way all the way down history and
into the time of the bible where solomon
would draw this shape and oil lighted on
fire and possess himself with demons so
it doesn't matter what name you call it
i'm talking about the exact same thing
so getting to the point about 10 000
years after the time of the
mesopotamians and the sumerians humanity
finally makes their way to space and
what do we see what you're looking at is
saturn's north pole now how did the
sumerians and the mesopotamians know
this how did they know that a six-sided
star is what represented saturn either
there is an extremely ancient and highly
advanced lost technology that we have
absolutely no remnants of
or this world is a lot more complicated
a lot bigger batter and darker than we
could ever possibly imagine and then
this hexagon right here in the
background it's the outline of the exact
same shape that we see on saturn's north
pole there is absolutely no coincidence
that these two things are in the same
shot please tell me another meaning for
that in the comments below why else
would they put it there
[Music]
it literally couldn't be any more
obvious you have four kids who are
sitting in what obviously looks like the
garden of eden with a bunch of animals
around them it's beautiful and
everything and you have these serpents
and the trees above them and they are
just absolutely hypnotized by these
serpents it couldn't be any more blatant
or obvious i i can't even get into this
one this is so easy
it's obvious
[Music]
[Applause]
and then here at the end they go out of
the way to show us the tiger and the
buffalo again and as you can see
the buffalo definitely only has one eye
yeah
oh wow
so who wants to kick it off
i want to say one thing before y'all go
in that puppet masters that are that are
running this show
they get off on the fact that they want
to do things out in the open a lot of
people think they want to be i guess
secretive or you know
hidden about all these things but they
really don't
they really get off on the fact that
they're doing these things in front of
our eyes and we don't even pick these
things up
and part of the ritual is that they have
to kind of give you this consent right
just like
um in babylon right when the two angels
haru tanmaru
you say we are but at trial so you have
to consent you have to give your consent
so by watching it and getting into it
they are they get your sort of
subliminal consent because your gaze is
still there so you're consenting to
what's going on because you're allowing
your consciousness to
receive the information it's like if
someone's screaming at you and you stand
there you've consented to like
let them scream at you you see what i'm
saying but if you leave you don't
consent
so they kind of have to do a bit of both
like you said it's it's like both of
them they like it but they also have
some type of spiritual
connection they have to give to you
it makes me think of um
like possession and stuff like that
where
in one way shape or form you have to
consent to it
yes and i'm talking about like jinns
you know like
if you have high iman if you're if
you're praying you're pulling thicker
and you're doing all this stuff in quran
reciting it
you can't like there's no way that a gin
can possess you
okay you know but what did they use in
the in the video you saw the
the beat right it's taken over them it's
a hypnotic like oh and
it's interesting how you can look at
that scene as a garden or jungle so in
the jungle is different laws in the
jungle right this is animalistic nature
in a garden you have sort of like better
behavior
you know if you go into a nice garden
you sit you relax it's very calm but in
the jungle it's like panic paranoia
anxiety
beet and if you notice
the tiger and the ox full of water
buffalo
actually joined together at the end
that's something really interesting it
it joins with its predator it's
oppressor
right it doesn't oh i'm free now i'm
going to run away it says no i was
almost killed so let me just sit here
and hang out
with my
you know predator which kind of shows a
lot about how these
certain you know
groomers are stockholm syndrome
there's psychological ways that when
someone victimizes you to keep you in
your spot so there's a lot of occultist
imagery in it
and i mean i get kind of disappointed
that the guy was like i'm not trying to
be conspiracy theorist about the masonic
eye
and it's like
it usually you know
if you're gonna take the egyptian
perspective is not much better because
the egyptians themselves
had strange witch roles as well but
it's not a conspiracy to say that
there's
masonic
imagery in big tech when so many of them
are themselves self-declared masons you
know what i mean there's open lodges
so why is that a conspiracy because to
conspire
means to set a plot to set an agenda to
have a strategy towards a goal
right when you build a building you have
to conspire to set the plot the literal
framework to build up the architecture
you come together you set a plan
it can fail and crumble
but you still had to go to a meeting
place to work it out
so i think it's interesting how
he tried to kind of get around the
censorship of youtube to be like i'm not
i'm not i'm not but i'm just saying but
i am not saying so i thought that was
really interesting because
uh it kind of gets into that that kind
of flip-flop logic but also i don't know
if you're familiar with this so the
tiger he mentioned the art style
uh today's art
is definitely meant to disturb you but
even since you know 16th century
renaissance art
i've studied art a lot i've taken a lot
of art classes unfortunately
and uh there's a
a lot of interpretations on how art is
supposed to make you uncomfortable make
you soft
but the alice allison wonderland
chester cat has a very similar grin
and that lion smiles and i mean not lion
tiger smiles in the same way
so if you were to compare the alice in
wonderland which is also you know a very
psychedelic disney
film
that's about drug use and tripping out
and the illusions they see all the
mushrooms and stuff the the tiger smiles
in the same way
and alice goes and talks to the chester
cat for direction now the tiger
he's trying to give direction to like
come into this frame because what
happens when you go into a frame
you go into a mindset your framework
so
when you go into something
you're willingly going in and you're
curious
they pass through right
that's what
are like everything has a boundary the
sharia is a frame
right you have literal laws secular laws
everything is a framework and if you go
outside of that
you're liable to punishment even your
phone just
the shapes of everything right
so
by you going into this framework
of a totally different reality where
even the flamingos were twerking you
know
it's like there's a twerking you know
big booty bird right here and then
the snakes are going and usually tree
snakes are you know oftentimes venomous
and then they have the tiger and the
buffalo linking up
there's so much things going on there as
you're around
this
very dangerous kind of weird hypnotic
environment
and you're enjoying it you're going with
the flow and you're not really paying
attention to
you're in front of a tiger
if it's like a real tiger you see it
like in india they'd be like we gotta go
like in china right in siberia we gotta
go there's a tiger here but the
anthropomorphism
of actual predators to condition you to
like it
with a nice beat and everything is you
know very smooth because the eye of the
tiger
remember those kind of songs from the
80s so it used to be about
taking out the eye of the tiger you
conquering the tiger now it's about the
tiger
giving you a chester cat smile and you
know bringing you in and getting you to
trust it so there's a lot
i mean animal fighting art is
interesting because
in chinese art
you see a lot of that
now he mentioned the uh
the that that art he did of the
zoroastrians i have a tattoo of the
assyrian uh
king asher bonapal
which is
drawn in the same way as it was on a
hieroglyph
ancient civilizations had a very
different depiction of
animals they watch different things
right
very raw
like okay a king had to go out and kill
a lion to prove he was a man today you
kind of can sit behind a desk and have
joe biden you know what i mean it's like
he went from very different sense of
power
you know
so
he has a point about how
it's interesting they chose that
depiction
a lot of civilizations did have
you know
they like that violent art because when
you watch it it's like hey i myself am
guilty of that if you show me two people
holding hands
okay this is really weird but if you
show me something in nature like
look at that lion hunt that giraffe like
look at that pack look at him tear it
apart there's something like very like
primal in that because we grew up around
that
i mean
we've had the internet for what not too
long so that used to be the old form of
entertainment so
it's interesting that a tech company
chose a primal image
right so if you think about the contrast
this is the future we're showing you the
primal of the past
and that primal animal which is
you know even in chinese zodiac type of
thinking
it is very strange that it's a fickle
creature
you can never really train a tiger look
at tiger king on netflix right how many
of he had a worker got her arm ripped
off
you can never really tame a tiger
you can never let your guard down around
a tiger you feed it and you watch your
back
right the japanese and the chinese and
the russians
and these ancient asian cultures were oh
and also india
where tigers were sold and bought people
learned a lot about tiger behavior
feline behavior now felines are usually
associated with women so if you think
about it
if let's say you make even though it
looks like a male tiger but let's say
you have like the female tigress
how many women have like stripper names
porn names around a female tiger how
many women dress up as tigers for
halloween
you know how how many women wear tiger
prints and jaguar prints right so it's
like you have a lot going on there of
all these twerking birds
the
ox buffalo
giving in to its uh predator
which also shows you just the sick mind
play
a kind of twerking party atmosphere
where you're going with the beat which
sounds like a rave if you've ever been
to horrible raves
you know they place house music and
techno and so it's like it's
overwhelming
movement of the body that's why you have
the snakes who are very like well very
into it so
you know a tiger if you approach it
while i was eating would usually attack
you
right this is my food but now they have
it the averse way don't run from the
tiger
stain and look at it and oh i must be
safe because he stopped and he smiled
you know how many predators of humans
smile at their victims you know what i
mean
showing human teeth like
a very corporate cold way is the very
clinical way
you know
ted bundy and these different psycho
serial killers they smiled in their
courtroom sessions so we confuse a grin
with safety which you know
it really just plays on how the kids are
really trusting not only a dangerous
animal
a dangerous animal as it's eating and
you're going into another reality
where you're like there's all these
poisonous animals
and there's these strange people
and we're just kind of going with it you
know and that's what the miniverse
is going to be it's going to be a total
immersion into your consciousness
so
your mind is going to be that jungle
frame you know it's really it's not you
think it's going to be a garden but it's
going to be a jungle and in the jungle
the laws of nature rule
there's no religion in the jungle
it's much harder a lot of people don't
know what the metaverse is but it's
basically like this it's like a vr
you know virtual reality you get real
estate you could do basically it's
limitless you could do whatever you want
to do that you can't do maybe in this
dunya because of a lot of limitations
religious restrictions
legal consequences so on and so forth
you could do whatever your even look at
the ad it said you know do whatever you
want at the end something like that and
uh i think that's that's what the
world's going into and it's gonna be on
the blockchain right those of y'all that
are familiar with crypto um and i agree
with you um
what are your thoughts when you got from
the video
i mean i said it i was i was on to it
but
uh like milan said
you've got these uh you got this imagery
in there
right
and like you said they can't fully just
throw something out there
blatantly but they can't completely hide
it it has to be some
there has to be something there because
there has to be acceptance that has to
be consent and then on top of that
once you consent there needs to be
submission
and think about like what was happening
to them when
the snakes were moving around like they
were hypnotized actually throughout the
entire thing they were just bobbing
their heads like this like
i've said this before but i think this
is a good reason why music is haram
you know we have the hadith that says
okay
basically all instruments are haram
that's what the prophet saw allah was
saying
now
is there explanation for this no but
allah gave us
our logic to be able to formulate
somewhat of an understanding and the
understanding is like listen to music
what happens when you listen to music
when it's something that you like
and you start your body starts kind of
moving
you start bob into the music and once
your body starts to move you've already
subconsciously submitted to the music so
whatever is being played in this music
whatever message is being said
whatever energy is being transmitted to
this music you're going to receive that
so think about this now
they're moving their bodies they're in
full submission you have all these
symbols that are it's basically letting
you know what you're getting into you're
in full submission so you're basically
giving consent to whatever is to come
from that so i mean
that's
that's crazy
that's crazy exactly and at the end i
mean we all know i mean most people
understand the huge symbolic meanings of
the owl itself you could do a whole
series on that
right from greek mythology to just
common native american folklore diablo
is the silent killer in the night if
you've ever seen an owl hunt at night
it's almost silent it'll snatch your cat
right off your porch pooft like whoa
what was that
and it kind of freaks you out because
you just see these big orange eyes
coming at you you know like oh man these
sharp talons so if
the predator bird the occultist symbol
of the bird
the
eye being you know out of
the ox
which also you know money
is usually represented by an ox wall
street the they have that giant bull
statue there is a lot of symbolism even
in zolastrianism and ancient
civilizations of cows
right bulls cows water buffalo
you know there's a lot of things to go
into that
so you have a lot of the animal allegory
mythology coming and remember
these people are millionaires who hire
teams to create these things it's not
just like
you know somebody at toys r us who's
like hey i want to go and make this you
know
multi-million dollar transnational
corporation an ad and ads are extremely
expensive
so
they're gonna get their money's worth
and facebook as we know
uh they
sell off your data i mean zuckerborg has
gone in front of congress and had to
testify i mean the senate was at the
center of the congress i think it was
the senate
uh but he had to testify
and
he does it without your consent but that
terms of service
we all click accept just to hurry up and
get through he's he he literally knows
so much analytics about your life that
you'd be freaked out if he were to
create an image of you on the screen
this is what you like on a tuesday this
is what you like on a wednesday and they
can nearly map out your entire
consciousness right they have a whole
team to figure out how to get you to
stay on the app so the metaverse is now
going into you as well
because once you put on those goggles
they're gonna create their own type of
currency it's gonna be too addicting i
love video games but i know i have to
regulate myself
i love red dead redemption too
i love it and it's fun but i know i have
to watch out because you're like this is
so much fun riding horses and shooting
other enemies it's so much fun
and time goes by so quickly you're like
okay i gotta watch it i gotta go pray
alarm goes off can't do this got
homework but the metaverse is even more
immersive
even more and it's going to be even more
addicting
and
we know that the digital reality of
transhumanists
this is what they kind of want
ai is coming
sorry it's coming to us we cannot get
rid of it anymore
they're expanding fiber octa cables
they're bringing more cell towers you
know
the digital realm the digital economy
everything is coming at us and robotics
are part of that they're gonna be part
of the military in japan they even have
you know robot servers they have the now
robot which is in classrooms
so as computer coders get involved they
create codes for robots and algorithms
for social media and zuckerborg is part
of both those worlds and he's very
friendly with a chinese developers right
he even speaks mandarin chinese
so
i think he's married to a chinese woman
as well
yeah so they're very into the digital
spirit it's very here and upon us
and the symbol of china is you know it's
the they have the tiger there's a lot of
tiger imagery in their culture
as well as the dragon
so
it's not a surprise that you have oh and
i i don't know if i already said this i
don't think i did
but the metaverse has tried to tell
religions to hold uh religious
ceremonies on their platform yeah
yeah so they they want religions to come
there and you know it'll be a very
filtered down uh
kind of uh they'll be able to track what
you're saying this is all it's about you
know surveilling you as well so you're
going to go into a totally artificially
constructed reality
where
everything will be on you
everything is going to be watching what
you do what did you look at how long did
you look at it for which colors incited
you what shape of the plant you know did
you like more it's all about you're
being studied basically you're gonna go
into this vortex
you are the ox you're going to agree to
it
and the tiger is going to be on you in
the jungle because the tiger stripes
help it blend into the atmosphere as it
stalks you
you are going to be in a digital
atmosphere and you're going to be
studied you are consenting to be studied
and your personal information will be
sold
and your mind your deepest intimate
thoughts are going to be recorded
and stored
on devices that will never go away and
if you have a bad memory it will always
exist in the digital sphere you cannot
get rid of it when you die
anyone will be able to hack it and
expose your most embarrassing private
moments right
so this is like a whole new arena of
private information imagine your diary
like if you're a girl
and that gets exposed or your girl
she you had a picture when you were a
little chubby and she showed it to
people now you'd be embarrassed now
imagine a corporation who
can blackmail you with your private
information that goes so deep into your
bodily and psychological analytics that
they can make you and coerce you to do
anything so you will side with your
oppressor under any condition in order
to get them to leave you alone and
you'll be so addicted to that metaverse
that you will do anything to get back
inside because it'll be better than your
regular life
escapism
because that's what thing is interesting
about video games is that
you get to kind of create what you want
you get to kind of behave how you would
normally behave i think we're all guilty
of
uh like sometimes i'll take my horse and
like run over some people
it's fun and you're like
you're like oh that's kind of that's
kind of bad but it's still kind of fun i
can't do that in the real world
but i just wanted to see what would
happen in the game
right
and what's interesting is hackers even
when you go online they can make an
alien appear in the game you're like how
did they do that
and like these gamer hackers can create
all things in the game that make game
developers upset
so imagine the metaverse
imagine how people can hack into that
because you know it's going to happen i
mean china has some of the best
cyber hackers in the world it's
literally part of their military right
so if they don't like you and your
message and you're in the metaverse all
day
and there's some dude who has an avatar
a very beautiful woman and then you find
out like oh that's a dude and then like
oh like it can really mess with you
psychologically and open you up to more
hedonism because now you're in a digital
paradise you can create any type of
woman
a furry
anything you can think of you can create
it and now it's going to be the the
better right it's going to be like the
beginner
but it's going to shift to be more
invasive more expanded upon because
that's what they want
if you're at home all day with vr
glasses on you're no threat to the
government
you're no threat to anybody you're
sitting inside
probably haven't taken a shower
you know haven't seen the sun and you're
inside i mean
if a playstation or xbox is addicting a
computer game imagine vr goggles where
the
the 4k imagery is going to be so
immersive you could go to mount everest
you could go here you could go there
i mean come on
that's how you get and then they're
going to argue with you and say well you
don't need a big house anymore because
you can go to the metaverse
and it'll take over your senses so where
you you'll feel like you're there but
you're not
right
and then you'll see houses get smaller
people losing kind of weight or getting
fat because of what they eat
it's a very structured way to be like
work at home then come home and plug in
i mean people used to make fun of others
for coming home and sitting down and
watching the television right
now it's plugged into the metaverse
and it's the beginning of it so now it's
all new and people are
resisting it
but
we know that digital
reality is coming our way this is what
they want a social surveillance creator
social credit score
digital passports this is the future
they're expanding to very rural areas
cell towers i mean
this is what they want i mean it's not
going to go backwards so we have to
manage it
as best we can and opting out of it
on a small scale
isn't going to stop these
bank-rolled companies from
getting your troll run i mean what do
you like think about zoom
right
they practice during the lockdowns how
can we get your kid in a digital box on
this computer screen to sit there
right
how can we have you have your work
meeting you don't have to go in person
anymore just sit right there stare at
the screen for eight hours
all right that data
was sold
those analytics are sold and zoom i
believe is also a chinese company
every single app has analytics and every
single thing you do
is sold to psychologists marketers they
want to know what's going on with the
human mind we are the cows we are the
chickens to them they are in a whole
different bracket of class right just as
a shepherd is not the same as his sheep
we peasants as they will look at us
they're on these are very elite people
who want control
right they can facilitate movement
through psychology so
the tiger
everything about it is just you can go
so deep with it and i think people who
study are people who study theology miss
and just politics in general
and who also distrust certain cyber
people can definitely see the
connections here
uh definitely
see the connections there because it's
no it's no hard
like stretch to say here's a smaller
frame go inside of it i mean
what are people doing with their phones
it's small but you're there
it's almost like a part of you and if
you study the transhumanists who
i understand not everybody has time to
study them
but
they want to merge with technology more
and more
right so it wasn't just
oh you're a veteran your leg got blown
off here's a robot leg now it's
how can we hack the human body to
live longer life extension technology
but they also brag about you know
reducing population reducing childbirth
right artificial wombs
the whole future for them
is
total and utter control and if you
notice all those futuristic sci-fi
movies
if you notice
none of them have the ability to stop
doing whatever it is that they're doing
they're part of that system so
they pull up and there's an alien and he
has all these analytics on the screen
right oh we have this we have that we
have this super ship
and
even in that spaceship floating in space
everything there can be seen and shown
even with things like black mirror squid
game
surveillance surveillance and then you
ask yourself who's watching the watchers
you know like uh
have some privacy again no you consented
you know wait a minute i just can't go
to the bathroom without you guys looking
at me you know
no
it's like jeez total
human control
in the past
societies did that with spies and
infiltrators today they just have
cameras everywhere and then those feed
into other places so
again it's it's it's gonna be
a jungle and if you know you know if you
look at jungle law you'd be like wow
thomas hobbes talks about natural law
i mean
going back to a primal state of nature
where might makes right
you know
it's gonna be it's hard for the godly to
stay godly in the jungle because
you you're gonna be in a very tense
survival mode
then you're surrounded by lush so a
mental jungle physical jungle
i mean
the delights
and
doors that can be opened
through
something like the metaverse is
something that parents have to consider
because
how many moms for example hear me out
say to their kids turn off the computer
turn off your phone let's go outside and
play the kids get angry they get vicious
like they're feeling they're being
punished
you have entire generations since
they're like three years old these moms
in the restaurants handing the phone to
their kids the kids stare at the phone
more than their mom the metaverse is
going to be a way in which they say
plug into the metaverse i don't need to
travel on an airplane to see you i'll
just see you in the metaverse so no more
human to human
feeling you know hugging
being with your family
hearing a real laugh it's all
here's your here's your filter and
you're being surveilled as you do it
you go meet your grandma ain't nobody
there meet grandma in the universe big
government is right there hearing
everything you say
that's a lot of power
a huge amount of power
and
somebody can also just pay and be like
hey
uh angel has a girlfriend i like is she
doing anything that i can you know
find out about and then they spy on her
and then show you what she did and you
know ruin your marriage you just never
know
you know god forbid but
i mean
there's just so many things that can
happen with it but they present it in a
fun way hey there's a twerking bird
like you know there's a very smooth
snake and as somebody who's played with
snakes you never trust a snake
you know you have to grab them by the
head and you have to watch them and if
they bite you you have to understand
that's a snake you can't get mad at a
snake for being a snake
a snake is a reptile they're not dogs
you know
you know and cobras will eat other
snakes it's just like
and they always shed their skin like if
you look at animals and then you wonder
why they use those animals you're like
hey the only friendly bird there was the
toucan just eats fruit you know it's
like geez
you know but
it's really quite fascinating you can go
on and on
i mean because people
they think you know it's not that big a
deal it's fun
but remember the mind is almost a
passive receiver most of the time to
actively make you
interested there has to be some type of
antagonism there but they took all the
antagonism away to lower your guard with
the music the bright colors and the
cartoonish images and the you know like
the happiness this is fun
you know everybody's doing it just get
in with the vibe so your guard is
totally lowered so when someone points
something out like hey that's kind of
weird
oh you're this you're that social
ostracization
keeps everybody in line
right just go in it's fine why are you
worried about it you don't want me to
have fun it's just like yeah but hey man
you've been in the metaverse for six
hours can we go on a hike or something
it's boring out there i can write a
dragon in the middle verse it's like
come on you know like you can see so
many things how it gets out of hand i
mean that's why china has decided
uh to only allow three hours a week
for games because they know
they realize they started to mess up a
bit
i mean it's powerful it's very
temptational
right it's it's just
really
it reminds me of the the movie player
one
y'all seen that
movie player one in player one
they have the virtual reality
and they have these suits that you wear
so not only
are you seeing everything perfectly as
if you were seeing with your own eyes
but you're it's it's taking control each
of your senses so controls like what you
feel
what you smell what you taste what you
hear everything as if like
the virtual reality is
just another real reality
you're just there versus
being here
so imagine that imagine if it gets to
that point
oh man that sounds scary
see i mean like i i i don't know man
like we got to get our kids
now we had to think about solutions
right so you know the metaverse is on
its way
how can you help slow it down
well i've been part of this movement of
you know starting a garden getting out
in nature
just stare from the sky
just try to you know have some livestock
get off of government dependency
you know learn about how do you travel
reading an old-fashioned map without gps
on your phone
how do you start a fire how do you build
a fire how do you build a shed how do
you chop down a tree without it falling
on you and how do you break it down
you know
it's like we have to get back to like
because remember cyber warfare can shut
down a city's electricity grid if you
remember hackers took down the oil
pipeline
and they took down a huge um
the uh
the meat supply company and even
t-mobile had their data hacked yahoo's
been hacked so anything with this signal
can be hacked so if you know that in the
future
we're not going to be dropping atomic
bombs on each other but that it's going
to be about attacking each other's
electrical grid each other's computer
systems because the subways run on a
computer if someone puts a virus or a
trojan horse in there shuts it down you
can't get home and you're stuck in new
york city with one grocery store few
cops and you know only the crazy people
have guns because they've taken away
your gun rights you're in trouble
right so
the
we have to get back to being like
you know
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
say practice with arrows practice with
arrows practice with arrows you can
learn to use a crossbow you can learn
how to fire a gun you can learn how to
take apart a chicken in the proper way
we have to learn that because if we plug
into this metaverse imagine if another
country takes down your infrastructure
with a digital virus in your computer
everyone is so
uh
soft addicted they don't even know where
how to find clean water their bodies are
used to 70 degrees
hey the heaters out you're gonna see
people
totally just freak out this can happen
but
we have people who condition us to
always think of the future as bright
when
anything can go back to the primal state
of nature the tiger and the ox predator
and prey in the jungle any time
and that
you know you you you have to be ready
for that i mean if you look at history
it's empire rise empire fall here's
their ruins have we not walked above the
earth and saw the ruins of those who
came before
the spider has the weakest home
the cables of electricity are the
weakest they're constantly causing fires
in california to where now they shut off
the power because they keep causing
fires and burning down homes and pg e
keeps doing a bad job
so
if we're in the metaverse california
says hey we're going to shut your power
off for two days because it's a heat
wave i'm out of the metaverse and now
i'm all mentally disturbed because i'm
like uh and with the invent of digital
currency the digital economy
and them kicking people out of the
workforce
you will see more dependency on like you
can work from home
work from home plug into the metaverse
see your family through the digital
means pay us for 5g
and we will make your life you will be
caesar
you'll be alexander in this digital
sphere just stay right there
you know don't pay attention just have
fun and you know ride that pink horse
that you wanted you know in the game
you'll have currency in the games
right in video games you have currency
it's not necessarily real you know you
can use your money
to there but you have hacking codes to
where you could just put money in there
right we all learn those codes and how
you can just hack the game
and then put in a certain amount of
numbers and stuff and you get your own
fake currency so there will be a time
where people
the food is delivered
you work from home so you have plenty of
time to be in the metaverse
so you're isolating yourself from your
real family
and seeing their avatar
you know and then they say like
oh your avatar will be able to have your
eyes and you'll be able to see it just
like it's you it's like why don't you
just go see them
you know but now it's like oh let's you
know distance
let's just distance from each other stay
away humans are gross they're all filled
with pests and
just be here in your little box
be here your apartment is a box
now go look in this box and have fun
within this box of reality we've given
you you're in a box in a box at a box
you know
so it's really deep
i mean it's fascinating truly it is but
average people who are busy they don't
have time
you know i can understand how to them
that's so analytical to where they're
like well i feel overwhelmed
so
best way to get around it
hold off
and encourage people to have their own
food supply raise chickens
get back to
what tribal peoples have done
for so long right don't think you're
safe just because
you get to go to starbucks and you know
you have
doordash and stuff like that you've got
to be able to survive on your own as a
man to protect your family you gotta do
it
you know you just really gotta do it so
that's what i would say is as a solution
think about a solution
think about how you can resist the
illusion of the digital world because
remember people will use drugs and then
go into the metaverse
now you're working with people
who have two layers
of mental illusion there the
hallucinations of drugs so people will
like
fentanyl
acid mushrooms
you know they'll get nice buzzed
go into the metaverse and they'll be
like this is so much fun
you know
then when you just have a regular
barbecue with your family no one will
want to show up because they're all
having fun in the metaverse
each person in the metaverse doing their
own thing
wife's downstairs husbands upstairs kids
are in their own miniverse the family is
completely atomized
right
and when a a broken family
is a family doesn't care about each
other and citizens who don't have a
family who don't own land who don't have
property have no ties to their land and
won't defend their land and won't care
about how their land is managed
and zuckerberg has actually started
sailing
real estate in the metaverse
so now
people are wasting their money and
buying a digital landscape that with a
blink of a button it could be all gone
instead of buying real land in the real
world and having a farm
it's really quite interesting
yeah the way in which you can go
there was a house that sold for 20
billion dollars on the metaverse
which is insane i'm just like bro don't
feed people buy stuff in the middle
versus the amount of soda you could have
given with that but while i'm just gonna
put you on pause for a sec oh no do you
have to go i know you had a coaching
call
yes
okay so just to reiterate for our lay
audience you know moms and dads that
they didn't come to the west for the
sake of making hijrah and spreading the
deen they probably just they were under
the facade of let's you know bring our
kids and give them a better life than we
had quote unquote so the average parents
are not too involved with their kids
they probably put their kids in public
school but they see this video they made
it this far and they kind of want to
take some takeaways now to implement
into their life um so what would you
have to say for parents but at least for
kids and those that are i guess affected
by technology to a greater degree than
they thought they would be
so i would say you know like basically
what you're asking is how do we kind of
help stem off some of this corruption
so essentially you gave some practical
advice like you know not relying on
let's say gps and using maps but like
what can they take away and start
implementing just like right from now
so right from now i would give them a
discussion about
addictions behaviors so
really i know it's hard like because mom
and dad are working they're tired
but
when you tell them to turn off their
phone say something straight which i
tell my little one
don't let the device control you you're
showing addictive behaviors don't get
angry and also you can do soft forms of
punishment of standing time out
and if they get ugh i'm bored i don't
want to go walk it's so boring you know
when you go on the walk
reinvigorate them with positivity wow
did you know that that plan takes this
long to grow oh did you know this make
it interesting
right that's why i do kind of things
with my little one is okay let's go
watch bugs how do you think they're
forming who do you think's the leader
the more you kind of exit the digital
sphere and have
like look at all of allah's creation
you can give your kid these facts that
will distract them from wanting to
distract themselves in the digital realm
because the digital realm is
really quick adhd uh entertainment with
bright colors and music
and so what you can do is detox from
that and actually get them surprised in
the real world so if you have land i
would say even a small space start a
garden with your kid have a beehive have
an ant farm have a worm farm have a fish
tank
teaching your kids how to be distracted
with something better because they need
entertainment they need stimulation i
understand
right not every kid will sit and build
with legos and a jigsaw puzzle like my
kid right you give them some
entertainment
but you also talk to them in a very real
way like hey you know
there's a benefit to being in the real
world
you know
and if you can afford it i would say
go camping go hiking go fishing get your
hunting license you know expose your
kids to the real world
you know the because
it's easy to
for them to be in school all day
they come home they watch tv
they get very bored and then the noise
the colors
the whole psychological pull into that
little vortex it's so strong for them
that you have to almost have pity for
them it's like talking to an addict who
is addicted to a pipe you have to kind
of slowly talk to them and take the pipe
away you put it over here
that's it come on like you really have
to get them piece by piece
and if they don't notice where you're
guiding them they'll fight it less
but if you get too angry too quick
they'll resent you as if you're holding
this wonderful gift back when reality
you're kind of saving them or at least
lessening the hold right like when i
watch something with my little one
i'll break down what's happening in the
cartoon
and then she'll be like really and i'm
like yeah don't you see it's kind of
weird that you know this character keeps
staring at this one that's the
propaganda and they should be like oh
oh this is haram i don't want to watch
this mom
right and they're like okay that's good
yeah yes i i tell her what is happening
and how to break it down and like you
can do this with your kid and it breaks
it towards like oh
now i kind of feel like i was tricked
you know and then they kind of trust you
more instead of seeing you as the mean
one
because when when they offer your kid
fun
fun
and you take that away they have now put
a wedge between you and your kid
as in you're the meanie you're the
oppressor you're this you're that
my teacher would let me do this someone
says moms let me does this they throw it
back at you so you have to be a bit
yeah you had to be smarter
you got to be smart because you don't
you don't remove something um because
they're going to resent you so you have
to remove it but you got to replace it
with something else to keep them
occupied
exactly and the thing i know some
moms might get mad at me but me changing
my lifestyle
how i work where i work how much time
accepting less cash so i can just focus
on my little one
that was really like now you have more
control and you can create and have time
and less stress to introduce her to
something better because you know from
their birth
to you know 18 years old is so
vulnerable and especially from you know
5 to 10
this is a key demographic of how they
try to come for you and your kids
because we have to remember
they are trying to engineer you know
they they want a pathway they have a
goal
technology is here
and
the less time you spend with your kid
you're at work
he's at work
they're in front of a screen
even the schools use screens
we're getting very very you know
strangely divided from one another
so
again
it sounds like oh it's a lot of work to
grow corn it's a lot of work to grow a
pumpkin patch but imagine you grow it
from seed with your kid
you harvest it you take it apart you
make pumpkin pie pumpkin bread and then
you tell your kid very excitedly you did
this and let's say you take pictures you
put in a photo album you have a little
celebration after like something very
cute make little cute decorations like
we did it
you can make it fun
you really can make it fun like
crafts and all this stuff for your kid
you can teach them things without
resorting to technology
it's you can also show them this is what
your hands put forth
right
instead of putting your hands down and
putting goggles on
you help make this happen by the
permission of allah and i would just
like even having chickens
yes you have to clean after them but
your kid will learn how to hold a
rooster how to not be afraid how to take
care of eggs
responsibilities they have energy you
have to put it towards somewhere
right you have them you like my little
one she writes little hadis she does her
stuff she has to do
but we have fun you know by going and
watching birds going by the ocean i give
her little facts that means i have to
read things you know like
okay if i see this particular snake
she's gonna ask me i want the answer and
if i tell her i don't know we go find
the answer even for you know different
types of rocks and minerals that i
collect i include her in everything so
she has a thirst for knowledge which
kids naturally have they're little
sponges
we stunt their growth if we put them
just in the digital realm and if we cut
back at work
we move to more rural areas we decide
not to go into credit card debt not to
have fashion
we go back to a minimalistic lifestyle
that's much better like me
i've been blessed by a lot i don't have
debt and so
like i'll make bread with my little one
and then i share it on instagram so
people can get motivated it's like she
sees this is how you do it
you know and even the yeast takes a long
time to rise but you teach kids patience
no you don't just go to the store and
buy it you can make it here's how
you know these are things we have to
teach the kids again which are our great
grandparents knew
so we have to kind of
not be as vulnerable and dependent upon
the government and the grid because the
more technology and power you give the
government
the more they will get intoxicated with
their own power to the point we are
totally oppressed
and if you know that these occultists
these atheists these godless people want
to rule you
they can stomp out your religion very
easily or even create fake narratives of
your faith
and when you speak out against it they
can just ban you because that's the
future d platforming debanking
you're out of society go away right
so we have to be off of their grid we
participate in it
but we have a parallel society like the
amish like these different you know
tribes all over the world
you have one foot in one foot out but
you can jump off ship any time and be
okay
so
getting your kid to do more fun things
so it depends where you live
right it depends where you live but i
guarantee you there's so many fun things
you can do with your kids for free on a
budget
even drawing in the sand even building
sand castles
right you go you go get a cup from your
kitchen
you just go and build sand castles with
your kid for an hour instead of plugging
into the metaverse right
so
get getting off
yeah
but that's basically what i mean
yeah yeah and uh i think this is a
really good starting point for future
discussions that we can have with rami
and honorable too this was i've
tremendously learned a lot from uh this
episode so i'm sure a lot of people that
are viewing this episode
also has and if they want to get more of
your content uh for those of y'all that
don't know she has a youtube channel
herself uh milan philosopher's corner
you've been on youtube a couple months
ago we filmed two episodes with you so
i'm gonna link both of them in the
description for anyone that's new to our
channel and hasn't seen any of them um
but yeah is there anything else you want
to say
oh no that's it and i know we went very
deep and analytical and expanded out but
just digest what i said and
do your own research look into
read some books on transhumanism about
control of food supplies
uh you know even how the military uses
you know the the technology what
facebook and them do with your data
who they hire
you know there's the information is
there you just got to go read it and uh
think about
getting back to nature
for this wonderful episode
and uh until next time salaam alaikum
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]